en ce jour de la saint valentin nous
débutons donc par une déclaration
d'amour celle d'horreur berges emmanuel
macron l'élu d'opposition les
républicains magny les hameaux en charge
de la campagne et digital d'alain juppé
pendant la primaire de la droite a donc
décidé de se mettre en marche
aurore bergé bonsoir vous êtes en ligne
avec nous vous avez annoncé aujourd'hui
votre décision dans une tribune publiée
sur internet publié sur l'obs vous êtes
une jeune trentenaire vous êtes engagé à
droite depuis vos 16 ans pourquoi ce
ralliement aujourd'hui auprès d'emmanuel
macron alors ce ralliement n'a rien à
voir avec la ford allan par an plus
sérieusement ça fait 14 ans que la
droite a beaucoup évolué en politique
vous allez plusieurs choix soit vous
suis et aveuglément la ligne du parti
quelle qu'elle soit quelles que soient
les circonstances
soit vous allez là où sont vos
conditions ça peut vous amener à
soutenir des gens qui sont différents
mais particules ou en carnet valeurs qui
sont les vôtres mois ses choix que je
fais j'essaie campagne ardemment retrait
d'alain juppé choisir un candidat à
cette élection mais comme hp n'est plus
candidat notre choix de son soin de
campagne les décisions et ce sont les
décisions les positionnements prix par
françois fillon qui ont une incidence
aujourd'hui sur ce ralliement auprès
d'emmanuel macron sans parler bien
évidemment des des affaires aujourd'hui
de la tourmente hausse autour d'eux des
emplois présumés fictifs
écoutez moi je voulais c'est tout le
paradoxe
[Musique]
il faudrait du jour au lendemain en
arreter de francs suisses on n'a pas
fait pendant la campagne de la primaire
et moi ce que j'ai dit pendant la
primaire
et notre salon pendant
l'entre-deux-tours de cette prime a ou a
eu quand même deux unions différentes de
la société qui se dégageait entre celle
d'alain juppé que je soumets et celle de
françois fillon et je peux pas dès le
lendemain en oublier ce en quoi je crois
et parkland sur la question des droits
des femmes
pour moi l'enjeu majeur qui est au coeur
de mon engagement que des années
travaillées et finalement vous ferme sur
le sujet on s'est quand même par essence
un engagement clairement françois fillon
a joué dans débilité tuera sujet qui
convoie fondamental qu'il a accepté sa
manie des hélas il faut laisser pas
juste parce que sa vente d'un ponte de
prendre la tva c'est une question de
valeurs à 70 jours de la présidentielle
une dernière question comment va se
traduire ce ralliement justement écoutez
moi c'est pas négocié de place pour
gagner
je le souhaite ardemment cadre l isc le
front national puisse gagner cette
campagne je pense que le seul qui peut
nous revenir aujourd'hui s'appelle
emmanuel macron je pense que j'espère
qu'il ya une vraie dynamique va se
montrer retour de lunel existe déjà dans
les finances les ânes leur marche avant
que c'est le premier engagement
politique qu'il faut c'est extrêmement
sans os x tu as ruiné mute kampala à la
vie politique y compris dans notre
département
j'espère que le plus en plus de
personnes vont se mettre
merci aurore bergé je rappelle que vous
êtes élu donc à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines actualité